food innovation has come a long way but
would you fancy eating crickets how
about algae and chia seeds new rules
governing novel foods have been a long
time coming the current legislation
dates back to nineteen ninety seven it's
opens door store the possibilities to to
have very clear regulation rules and
that opens door to small and medium
enterprises it's a simplified procedures
so both George daughter to be more
fasting procedures one ambiguity meat
from cloned animals has been taken
outside of the scope of the legislation
but foodstuff made from nanomaterials
are included detractors say as a step
too far and the cost is consumer
protection until we do not have a
analyzing methods until we do not have a
proof that using of non open a new
material seen in food is safe we should
ban it but many foods like donuts
chewing gum chocolate can contain tiny
fragments of nanoparticles so if we're
already eating them just how concerned
it should we be it's very clear that the
labeling is there it's as clear as can
be before the consumer a cutie receives
that that food at the plenary on
Wednesday MEP is approved the new
legislation a boost for food innovation